all right in early March of last year
the Attorney General Jeff Sessions was
new on the job he had just been
appointed by presidents from and just
confirmed by his former peers in the US
Senate he vowed to uphold the law of the
land as America's top cop without
skipping a beat sessions stunned
President Trump the entire political
world he decided to recuse himself from
the single biggest most important case
facing not only the administration but
the entire country the ongoing so called
Russia collusion investigation so we
have the country's top lawyer
immediately recusing himself from the
single most pressing legal case without
any prior warning to President Trump or
those who confirmed him to the US Senate
you probably remember this I asked for
their candid and honest opinion about
what I should do about investigations
certain investigations and my staff
recommended refusal they said that since
I had involvement with the campaign I
should not be involved in any campaign
investigation I have studied the rules
and considered their comments and
evaluation
I believe those recommendations are
right and just therefore I have recused
myself in the matters that deal with the
Trump campaign
yeah career people now what former
senator and attorney general sessions
did at this point is so harmful the
ramifications so massive his decision
that day the day after he's confirmed is
playing out today and it's hurting the
country and according to Fox News legal
analyst our friend Greg Jarrett who will
join us soon the Attorney General used a
completely illegitimate justification
for his refusal sessions remember he
cited that he was required to recuse
himself under us cold Federal
Regulations 28 CFR 45 point to because
of an ongoing criminal investigation
however at the time of sessions refusal
there was no Russia collusion criminal
investigation it was
in counterintelligence inquiry in fact
the criminal investigation only started
after sessions recusal upon the
appointment of the special counsel
robert muller and here we are today and
now robert muller
is even reportedly investigating now
he's desperate he's panicking he knows
this is blowing up a meeting that took
place between Trump and sessions that
took place shortly after the president
was blindsided by the his own Attorney
General's decision to recuse himself on
day one does anyone really expect a
sitting US president not to question his
brand-new Attorney General's decision to
sit on the sidelines recuse himself the
day after he is literally confirmed in a
case when he's taken the job the next
day and by the way the president can
order an attorney general as Gregg
Jarrett told us last night to indictment
to make an indictment out make an
indictment to investigate or not
investigate something
so there's frankly nothing unusual or
illegal about this meeting will have
full analysis and while more on the
Muller issue in a moment but tonight we
have so many other important lingering
questions for the Attorney General Jeff
Sessions why didn't he tell anybody the
likelihood that he was going to recuse
himself before he was confirmed or
before he was appointed how in good
faith can a attorney general act without
participating in the single most
pressing legal case facing this country
facing this administration and now we
can all see the damage of Muller's
witch-hunt investigation and what it is
a flawed witch-hunt why he should as we
have talked about months and months ago
unruhe cues himself immediately this
time he would be following the correct
law without a doubt when the Attorney
General Sessions well I have personally
always liked and respected what he has
done here has now left this
administration and country more exposed
to the deep state that has been working
against the president you elected since
the very beginning this last week we
learned that at least one informant
likely more working in coordinate
with the Obama Justice Department
actively infiltrating the Trump campaign
spying on a multitude of people
associated with in candidate Trump's
election efforts and here's what two of
the men who were spied on had to say on
this program right here last night take
a look I think what this meeting was
about was that they used me as a way to
get an introduction to George and he
wanted to go to George papadopolis and I
think and he and he is Carter page to
get to me and then he used me to get to
George and then I really think that was
the whole chain of the whole chain of
events there I believe I got least two
and and and perhaps more approaches by
by individuals who were trying to offer
information to the campaign that would
have jammed us up in some way shape or
form I mean it's very clear that salmon
and Carter were both us approached by a
spy lying to FISA judges repeatedly not
telling the FISA judge is not
corroborating not not not verifying not
telling FISA Court judges getting warned
spying on Trump campaign associates all
of this happen and you know something
now we got spies that we're discovering
that we're in the Trump campaign and as
much as the media says oh it's not
actually spying it's an informant you
just heard for the three men that were
approached by the so called informant
who's really a spy to tell them and seek
out information because of this witch
hunt that began is we as we now know in
the spring of 2016 I'm even unlisted to
chairman Gowdy today who frankly I agree
with on a lot of issues he tried to play
down with the president is rightly
calling Spygate let's make this very
simple
here are the the basic thesaurus
definition of the term spy for all of
you people in Congress even those of you
that claim to be lawyers a secret or
undercover agent that's a spy so make no
mistake this mistake the Trump campaign
was spied on a secret agent working with
Obama's Justice Department monitoring
conversation and activities of many
Trump campaign associates you just heard
directly from the individuals who were
spied on and actively targeted by the
spy and
chairman Gowdy praising the FBI's
overall handling of the Russian probe
know chairman Gowdy look at McCabe look
at Comey look at struck look at page
look at Loretta Lynch look at all the
others that abuse their power so we got
to get this right the FBI literally
under fired FBI director which the
president had every right to do rod
Rosen Stein himself recommended James
commis direction used Hillary Clinton's
bought and paid for dirty dossier full
of Russian lies put together by a
foreign agent and illegally convinced
FISA judges because they're supposed to
verify and corroborate to authorize a
wiretap against the Trump campaign
associate in the lead up to a campaign
all while the Obama administration is on
masking the names of American citizens
caught up in other surveillance at what
is a three hundred and fifty percent
increase from any prior year and while
the FBI was using spies to monitor at
least four people associated with the
Trump campaign chairman Gowdy keeping up
and let's not forget after James Comey
was fired from mishandling the Clinton
investigation called me illegally leaked
documents he wanted a prompt the
appointment of a special prosecutor
because his BFF Robert Muller who then
appointed let's see the most corrupt the
most dishonest married band of
anti-trump Democratic donors those
people who are now doing everything in
their power and have been to take this
president down how do you ever trust any
special counsel that would hire Andrew
the pit bull Wiseman how would you ever
trust them let's see
he lost tens of thousands Americans
their job at Andersen accounting
overturned Supreme Court nine zero put
four innocent Merrill executives in jail
for a year and that was overturned by
the Fifth Circuit you want him
investigating you any congressmen out
there give me a call now there are so
many brave public servants that are
doing important work in the FBI in the
CIA in our intelligence community some
very high-ranking but we have now
discovered abuse of power bad apples
that have a political agenda that are
hell-bent on destroying this
d legitimizing him and literally ruining
the vote of the American people and by
the way in their eyes this was the man
that was never supposed to be president
and they were counting on it now there
are fears that Muller's ongoing
witch-hunt will influence the midterm
elections I believe this is a legitimate
concern now former New York City Mayor
Caron Trump attorney Rudy Giuliani who
is with us tonight will join us live in
a little bit weighed in on this very
issue earlier today take a look maybe a
mistake and maybe the American people
have concluded that impeachment is not
proper they go to do everything they can
to say the target on the future
everybody in this town knows they so
tonight it's not just President Trump
it's not Republicans worried about this
political impact of Muller's partisan
fishing expedition he couldn't find one
Trump donor not one in fact top Senate
Democrat there's now political fears
kicking a Mark Warner telling a crowd he
fears Americans will start to grow tired
of the investigation if it is not
wrapped up this year oh yeah they're
tired of it already take a look
the notion for those who may be
partisans in the crowd say well gosh you
the Democrats take control they'll be
able to really ramp these up I think the
American public will be will be tired of
it if this is not wound down in this
calendar year what a judge Ellis a why
do you go back to Paul mana Ford's case
oh you go back to mana for it you put
the screws to him so he'll sing or he
may compose so that they will get
information they can use to prosecute or
impeach the sitting president a duly
elected president that judge Ellis was
dead on accurate and according to a new
poll from CBS News a majority of you the
American people you are rightly now
already skeptical of Muller's efforts
believing that the special counsels
investigation is what it is politically
motivated
now while this off the rails Russia
so-called collusion investigation rolls
on way past way beyond any mandate they
ever had well the President of the
United States well he actually has real
work to get done including the
negotiations with North Korea already
the president has secured the release of
several hostages once held captive in
North Korea Kim jong-un he's no longer
firing missiles over Japan and
threatening Guam and the entire Korean
Peninsula were threatening the United
States the nuclear tests have halted he
crossed the DMZ and hours ago a top
North Korean official landed right here
in New York City for a meeting with
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo the two
men just finished a working dinner and
according to Pompeo the meeting went
great a historic meeting between Trump
and Kim jong-un is now still in the
works it may happen on time